the second round pick in the 2003 NFL
Draft has decided to hang them up saying
quote unquote my life's purpose is
bigger than football at this time I feel
drawn to make the larger fight for human
rights a priority that's Anquan Boldin
here on the show how are you Antoine I
am doing great let's let's talk about
your decision to retire after signing
with the Buffalo Bills did you just
decide one day after practice you know
what I'm I don't want to do this anymore
I don't have it anymore or what was your
process going through this
Anquan well for me I still had the
passion to play football
um I mean for me football has been
something that I've always wanted to do
since I was a kid
so it wasn't that I you know wasn't able
to play football anymore didn't happen
that passion or the desire to play I
just so I'm led to do something else
it's been an honor for me to be in the
NFL for 14 years not many guys can say
that so I definitely feel blessed to
have that opportunity um but I think at
this point in my life there's something
that's more important and what is that
more important thing I'm fighting for
justice fighting for equality in this
country um I think anybody with a post
can see how divided we are as a country
right now and it breaks my heart to see
where we are as a country and I think
the only way that we can fix where we
are is if we as people stand up and
fight they and justices that are going
on would you still be playing football
today if Charlottesville did not happen
there's a possibility but for me it
isn't just about Charlottesville
for me I've been concentrating this for
a couple years now when I was in San
Francisco I unfortunately I lost my
cousin to an undercover officer
my cousin broke down on the side of the
road and it cost him his life and I
think for me that event started the
cycle of me I'm thinking about
retirement
Anquan Boldin joining me here
on the Rich Eisen show so how will you
go out into the community now and try
and accomplish what you want to
accomplish welcome you I'll continue to
champion the efforts that I've been
doing for the past couple years you know
we have programs in place I'll continue
to advocate for those that don't have a
voice I'll continue to try to mend the
relationships between the community and
police I'll continue to go to Capitol
Hill and try to get different laws and
bills passed I'll continue to meet with
senators and congressmen on both sides
of the aisle to try to bring this
country together man like I said I'm
heartbroken about what I see from as a
country the hatred that's going on the
bigotry that's going on I don't think
for me as a father of two two boys I
wouldn't be comfortable leaving this
earth and leaving my two sons in the
America that I see today what would you
say to those who hear this Anquan and
say how can an Kwan bold and make a
difference when we are so divided as a
country well for me I would be naive to
think that I could solve all of the
problems that we have in this country
but I do think that I can I can make a
difference I think we all can I think
the thing that we don't give ourselves
enough credit for is you know stepping
up to the plate and being able to make a
difference I think if everybody felt the
way that I felt and everybody you know
chipped in and and put words to action I
I think you would see a difference so
what do you make of the protest in front
of the league headquarters on behalf of
Colin Kaepernick yesterday Anquan I
think all of the protests right now that
are going on is people crying to be
heard I think people understand that
there is a divide in this country I
think people understand and see that
there are some injustice and unfairness
that is going on
people want to be heard people are
crying out my that's he players on the
sidelines taking the knee and for those
players is not about disrespecting the
flag is not about districts but
disrespecting the veterans who have
fought so hard for the freedom that we
have but it's more so about the things
that gods have to deal with I think one
thing that people don't really
understand is just because you're
professional athlete doesn't exempt you
from the things that go on in in
everyday life you're still you're still
the citizen you're still dealing with
the things that everybody else deal with
you just have an opportunity to live out
a dream to play a sport that you've
always wanted to play but we're no
different than anybody else like I said
being a professional athlete didn't
prevent my cousin from being killed
being a professional athlete doesn't
prevent me from being racially profiled
or pulled over just because of the color
of my skin so don't don't get it twisted
I just because you're you're being paid
to play a sport doesn't exempt you from
every every day I'm part of life yes and
I am a thousand percent with you Anquan
I am in a position though that I want to
give the opposite viewpoint some airing
with you right here and that is that yes
you are an athlete and have every right
to use your First Amendment rights as
Colin has done and everyone else but why
on company time if you will I mean you
you are you are leaving the game so you
can hit Capitol Hill and you can do the
things that you are saying needs to be
done in this country
why then take a knee during a game when
people are tuning in to watch you play I
believe you guys are doing that because
that's when they're most visible if guys
did it in practice it will go unnoticed
media isn't there to take notice of it
people aren't watching practice so I
think guys are doing it at a time when
they're most visible and as you can see
it's it's drawn a lot
attention to the collars the things that
I see is even a year before Colin took a
knee I was advocating for some of the
same things because I had lost my cousin
a year prior to and as loud as I was
talking as much as I was trying to get
the message out nobody listens but as
soon as Colin took a knee it was the
conversation everywhere around this
country and barbershops and schools and
everybody's home everybody was talking
about it in churches you name it
wherever you went the conversation came
up so I think it was a necessary thing
to happen to be able to bring this
conversation to the forefront and I'm
gonna ask you the million dollar
question than an corner of the moment
and that is would you advocate people to
boycott the NFL should Colin Kaepernick
not have a job when toe meets ball on
the season on September 7th between the
Chiefs and the Patriots I think
everybody has to make a decision for
themselves I think you have some guys
that are comfortable with boycotting the
NFL and I think you have some guys that
are just the same way as you have some
some players in the industry that are
comfortable with taking this thing in
and you have others that aren't I think
it all depends on where you are as a
person
so before I let you go Anquan how can
people who have heard what you have said
saw what you put out there in your
statement or listening to you right now
how can how can we support you how can
you be supported I can be supported by
the programs that we have in place I can
be supported by different op-ed letters
that we're writing we can be supported
by different bills that we're trying to
get passed I think there's there's a
difference different ways that you can
support this movement and I think
there's different tiers
to it we have a lot of guys in the NFL
they are not taking these on the
sidelines but guys that are going on
social media and reposting tweets that
we have we have guys that are willing to
implement different programs in the
communities that they're in and then we
have guys who are comfortable enough to
to go and take meeting in front of
congressmen and senators on trying to
get different bills passed so I think
there's different levels that people can
get involved but I would just encourage
everybody in some some form of fashion
to make sure that they get involved at
Anquan Boldin on twitter as well and you
know Anquan I'd love to have you back on
a check in with you periodically as to
how you are doing on this front anything
that we can do here to get people
together in this country and love and
not hate I'm all for it and then another
time we'll have you on we'll talk
football if you're up for it definitely
appreciate you for having me on [ __ ]
always Anquan I've always enjoyed
talking with you and you know I always
heard about you from prime before you
even stepped on a field in the in the
National Football League so
congratulations on 14 great years Anquan
thank you you bet that's Anquan Boldin
Anquan Boldin on twitter the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy